I seem to struggle like it especially
when you play enough 960 it's like ah
the same ol d 4 d 4 C 4 it's kind of
like that okay well I don't know a lot
about it but give it a shot
the King was a gambit the King's gambit
accepted and this is the bishops gambit
I don't I think this is the extent of
the bishops gambit line that I know and
only with chess cubes help it says it
I'm right there you can't say it but the
bishops gambit is showing okay d4 Knight
c3 or just get my night out right away
I'll go get my night out right away
bishops gambit so what did what's the
scoop why are they calling it that
because there's some sack on f7 is that
what ends up happening ok I'm catching
in the corner of my eye somebody saying
in the twitch chat that the Kings gambit
accepted was solved recently whoo is
that the truth I have to remember to
ignore spectators their unjust cube
let's get in let's get in d4 I don't
know that this is right I guess the
Knights intending b6 anyhow I think you
might want to do your homework on that
uh that Kings gambit accepted being
solved it's back up my bishop does not
want to be captured by that night I do
not want to allow that night bishop
exchange either don't want to lose a
piece don't even want that type of
exchange my bishop is better placed than
the night and I think the first game I
was talking about how my queen was
boxing out the night by
- by having two squares in between the
night in the Queen well similar thing
going on with the bishop two squares of
separation the night is boxed out the
advancing squares the night cannot be
making use of a three or a four
I like a four I don't even want this
pond to get on my side of the board and
be cramping to me also if this pond was
able to get to a four that means that
maybe maybe this is a big maybe maybe
the row could get to a five and then
swing over laterally I'm not really
seeing that as being too likely but just
just to emphasize the new possibilities
that would be present pressure on e what
do you do develop the night yep as a
follow-up I think um I just take this F
for pun and I'm regaining my material
however black could be really stubborn
and say you know what you're gonna have
to work harder you're gonna have to work
harder I'm not gonna give that pond up
but they're not saying work harder with
that move I think the the move that
would say work harder is Knight h5 which
is a little bit scary to do because it
is unprotected my queen has an eye on
that diagonal but now I think it's been
it's safe to say at this point it's
clearly a success because I'm not
playing again but I'm not playing down
material and this is a good center let's
but that's not always enough is it you
have to to make it work you have to
really show that advantage a bit more so
what would I be looking to do as
follow-up from this point if you be
going with d5e five what is the pawn
move to be going with I think this is a
I move to get in hmm play it now I would
like to have this point come under some
fire I don't like being in this pin
might there be a c5 move right around
the corner Queen e1 to g3 or Queen to d3
I think I like yeah I think I like Queen
to e1 you need one I'm gonna go with
that Queen e1 just get out of the
nonsense there let's get out of the pin
my knight is back to being to full
strength
and yeah there's there's no there's no
issue with moving the knight now Queen
g3 pressure on the bishop opposite this
pawn right here pinning that Jeep on to
the king and what else what else is the
plan there
we're gonna see with d1 Queen g3 okay
the recapture I think without a doubt is
with the rook you really better have a
good reason to recapture with the pawn
in this case this rook is already on a
half-open file keep them there
this Knight is ready to pick off my dark
square bishop don't really care about
that I do let's hang on to him as a
follow up queen F to rook F one serious
pressure being placed on f7 now however
one more thing to consider if I play
here there's gonna be Knight g4 so let's
just stop it
this move doing two things guarding g4
later on this is a better flight square
than f2 most likely for as long as the
Queen's are still on the board at least
or well I don't know I think the main
one is just watch over g4 I don't know
if you could really claim that it's good
for a flight Square
I don't know that h2 would be any safer
than g1 being that there's a queen still
on the board a dark square Bishop still
on the board so
um I've really better have a good reason
once again to not get all my pieces
working so f7 next step is this move
right here this is one that I was
talking about earlier I could get it in
and now this pawn is there's no good
defense to f7
as soon as that Knight moves three more
pieces are hitting it to will one right
now directly a second directly in to
indirectly I could I'm considering
either capture here with either the
Bishop rook or maybe even first a pawn
push I think taking with the take with
the rook or take with the Bishop if I
take with the rook I think the King has
to run to the corner if I take the
bishop the rook has to definitely give
itself up I recapture the knight takes
the pawn is hitting my rook I like
something with I think rook takes King
here
oh I'm not seeing it through our wait
pawn push first no I'm not really liking
that either let me just be assured of
some material here this definitely has
to be taken with the rook and now Knight
takes here to be a little bit cautious
so okay I'm let me retreat to an active
spot this is active pressure on the
knight in such an open position trying
is to try try your best to just keep
pressure on your opponent's pieces so
I'm looking to reposition
ever-so-slightly here and I think this
is a good spot for my dark square Bishop
I want to be cautious of the bishop
playing here I'm really tempted now to
just break this down
taketake or could I consider push push
mm yeah you know I'm not gonna take that
I don't want to give that up just yet
I'd like to get to get rid of this night
this one is not as much a bother as this
one let's trade a little bit
simplification and watch out for the
tricky Forks whatever you do do not fall
for a fork and I think that that night
is officially out of squares now good
spot form right here followed by a pin
no time okay
good game let's back up and see if we
could make an improvement I didn't mean
to how many times I click on I usually
only do it during the tournament I visit
that merchandise store every so often
donate and always by mistake okay let's
see you really have to be I think you
need to know some theory with the Kings
gambit and I don't know if I could even
offer what the theory is on it but what
I have seen is that this move right here
this g5 move is played to really try and
make me work a bit harder to get that
pawn back and I think there's if I'm not
mistaken that and this is a look this is
definitely fuzzing for me but I've seen
something like g5 castle maybe even g4
and then well no no not g4 right away
something like g5 castle mm maybe like
h6 or Knight knight c6 and then after d4
something like maybe even sacking this
Knight
I don't know I'm mixing up my thoughts
as you could definitely hear something
with g4 and that just a little g3 excuse
me g3 if there is this g5 move geez
to break down the structure in something
like if g4 is played you end up just
capturing I don't know I'm Way off with
this and clearly I don't even know if I
should be saying it just thrown um I'm
fishing for the words here I just don't
know the exact line that I'm trying to
recall here something with G 5 and H 6
maybe even Bishop to e7 I don't know let
me maybe focus on things I can say a bit
more confidently because I'm definitely
not confident with what exactly black
should be doing here the knight move I'm
not so sure about blocking in that
Bishop so maybe maybe there's something
else like getting this Knight to f6 and
then h5 you could be maybe thinking
about that or again G 5 H 6 type of
stuff
the knight is boxed out but right here
another thing to view it as is if you
don't make me struggle to get this pawn
back if you don't make it a little bit
inconvenient for me this is a tremendous
success because of the center that I
have and again I'm not playing being
down upon anymore so I guess the the
summary is try and make it a bit more
difficult to let me get that pawn back
because otherwise I'm just have a really
good position now how you exactly do
that I'm not sure again I've turned off
the g5 move I don't know the exact
continuation but okay we're in the
King's gambit accepted there's a lot of
resources out there so you can look into
it maybe a bit more
how's that for advice hey this is the
King's gambit you go you look stuff up
for yourself and learn anyhow just know
that if you're not making me struggle
there then it's a definite advantage for
white no material loss and a good Center
and a well placed Bishop boxing out the
knight
so forth and so on okay let me close out
sorry I wasn't of more use to you but
just being completely honest if I don't
know it I'm gonna tell you hey I don't
know it there's a lot a real life that I
just do not know and that's one of them